SPEAKER 1: Thank you very much.
This is my second time at an
Android Game Developer Summit.
It is really good
to be here and I
can see the faces I
have known before,
and I hope they
enjoy this session.
We'll talk a little bit about
Vulkan and also some problems
we can face during
the real world.
And I'll invite
Ito-san and Enji-san
to talk about more their great
creation on the "Final Fantasy
XV Pocket Edition"
as a best practice.
So I'm [? reading ?]
GPU driver team
and also game dev tech team
in Samsung mobile division.
So we'll start with the Vulkan.
So let's try this.
Who already knew about Vulkan?
Many Vulkan developers.
Who are really engaged with
your Vulkan project now?
There's some of us.
[? A usual ?] thing, yes.
So Vulkan is not new thing.
The Vulkan published from 2006
in February [? Acronis, ?]
and multiple companies really
hard effort to making that
happen right on time.
But still we are
saying that Vulkan
is a future API or something.
It's meaning it's not
perfect yet, maybe.
So because of growing of
importance of the gaming
and under it is
really higher than--
and also you can see a market.
And the business is merging
between a PC and mobile more
and more.
Like new [? drawing ?] in mobile
battle royale and PvP games.
And what we've seen similar
with MMORPG and [INAUDIBLE]..
So that the expectation
from the user
is a little bit
different because there
are different areas
or different platform.
Because these users coming
from PC and console,
they really care about
the fidelity of the game.
But in Android,
the mobile devices
are still in some limitation,
because the battery technology
is not enhanced a lot.
So it's stuck on somewhere
during recent over 10 years.
So there are still many hurdles
to limited budget of the power
and performance.
So the new technology is really
required to overcome that.
So the optimization itself is
really important than ever,
but you can imagine easily about
the traditional optimization
is just a trade off between the
quality and also performance.
If you want to
increase in more FPS,
then you're just dropping down
your fidelity of the game.
But that user's expectation
is something like this.
Even just five inches
[? of ?] your mobile phone.
And how you can overcome this--
what is advance optimization?
What is the fundamental
solution for that?
You go with a better quality
but better performance.
We think that Vulkan
is one of the answers.
Am I right?
I'm not sure.
But I am sure of several
things, even if Vulkan is not
so perfect but still works.
And because many people already
knew about what Vulkan is,
so I'll just run through
this really quickly.
The Vulkan advantage is
cross-platform support
and lightweight, predictable,
explicit control.
And there's a bunch
of great tools
to help you to
optimize your game.
That is backed.
I'm not lying.
And yes, there's
the low overhead.
You can add more
[? drokols ?] than GLES.
Does not means you can
cover 3,000 [? drokol ?]
for your game, but is maybe
three or four times more
[? drokols ?] you can cover
with Vulkan than GLES.
So I heard sometimes
about our partner
game developers mention a
game is really slow, even
with the new Galaxy S9.
I saw that is at
2,000 [? drokols. ?]
It's not so capable to
be covered on a device,
even with up to date model.
But it's still that is capable
to do more [? drokols ?]
with the Vulkan than GLES.
And more controllability
you can have
does not mean that you can
resolve any issues with that.
But you have more margin
or way of control things
that feed into your content
for better performance.
It's not just a
command [? bots, ?]
or command before submission,
but also the other things too.
Like from allocation of
memory, binding the memory,
copying the memory, and also
to merging the render passes
and making cell passes.
There is a grouping
that passes into the one
or split, the timings, so on.
And the other various way of
optimization you can have.
You can make more better
management of the resources
and can have more a way
of reusing your resources
you used before.
That means that there's more
possibilities you can optimize
or improve things better than
GLES, because GLES there's
not many things you
can do unless you
can have a implementation.
But Vulkan you
can see many ways,
even if that is not giving
you that twice or a third time
better performance.
But you can find a small
amount of improvement
that also can give
you more capability
to do things more you can show
to people, make differences.
So yes, we can see that twice or
a third time better performance
FPS with the sample demo.
We made some cool
demo, Protostar,
for our [? S7 ?] [? unpack. ?]
But that is just a demo and
the samples we're showing off.
The real world is not
that simple like this.
It's more complicated than that.
And it could be thing you--
the Vulkan is a
kind of the magic
and just click the part and
everything is going better.
But real world, that is not.
So you have to do something and
sometimes you cannot get any
benefit of that.
So it means that Vulkan
as advanced technology
can deliver you more optimizing
your content with better
quality and better
performance at the same time.
But it could not be the solution
for your content sometimes.
So during our collaboration
with [? expressive, ?]
with our partner game
companies, and there
are new [INAUDIBLE]
gaming problem with 2016.
Our game developer support
program Galaxy GameDev.
We struggled with many
issues and problems.
So now I will talk about
the real world problems we
learned from those experiences.
Yes, the Vulkan has
some advantages.
But it is not so
simple and is not
so all solution for all cases.
If you do just porting
API from GLES to Vulkan
and that implementation
is proper,
then you can have a quite
big improvement in CPU.
That is true.
But it's not giving you
sometimes better performance,
because it sometimes
is bounded by GPU fully
or your implementation
is not wrong,
but it's not well fitted into
a certain game, a certain GPU
architecture.
So the GPU is the real
problem, yes, partly.
There's some part
of that the GPU
driver is the issue because
that the quality is not enough.
Sometimes the game developers
on the console and PC,
they complain about that
the mobile GPU is not
enough performance.
It's because that
mobile GPU is running
on just less than 10 watt
power, but your GeForce
is running with over
100 watts or something.
It's 10 times bigger
power budget they can use,
so the mobile GPU is--
you have to bear on it.
Those two quality and
performance issues
is just fundamental thing.
Quality we are now trying
to improve more than that
with the Google and also
the other GPU vendors.
But still there's
something remained.
So the GPU is not the
real problems, partly,
because you are wrong
targeting the power budget
and performance target.
So it's bounded by
fully GPU because you
overloaded the fidelity
of the graphics
to over work your GPU a lot.
That will not give
you any benefit.
And also your implementation
is not well fitted
with certain GPU architecture.
That is also one of the problem.
So you have to figure out with
some optimization or better
policy to target the power
budget and performance target.
So for chasing that
topic, the developers
really need to have some way
of optimizing and analysis
or something.
So the simplest way is just
delivering better game engine,
including all the solution.
But as you know, the Unity
and UE4 is not that level yet.
Oh, sorry.
And also, we have
to bring more better
tooling to understand more--
to deliver a better way
of the game developers
to understand more about their
games running on a device
inside.
And also, delivering
a more better way
of interacting the OEM and GPU
vendor to share your feedback.
You can share about
similar things
what I'm now talking about, and
that many times former session
also Google guys
now talking about.
So the vendor channel
is there and also you
have a Google channel.
But the problem is when
you found that AGP driver
box, then wherever you contact
with, the vendor or Google,
but is not give you
fix your problem.
Because the driver
fixes should be
shipping into the real
product, into the market,
so we have to know about
that kind of thing.
But usually the game developer
doesn't have any channel
to contacting with OEM.
That is really hurt the
situation around the ecosystem,
so we are now
seeing the game dev
and you can contact with
the game dev at samsung.com
anytime if you want.
And the last one is the better
guidance about power budget
and performance target.
I want to really
talk more about this.
Power budget.
So my personal opinion, you
have to avoid the GPU bounding
situation at all
with your content.
So there is three
bounding types.
One is CPU bounding and
second is this GPU bounding.
And the best case is a
non-bounding situation.
So if you have the three
different type of situation
with your GLES build,
and after Vulkan port,
you can have some benefit
with the Vulkan with the CPU
bounding in normal situation,
but you cannot see any benefit
with Vulkan port with
the GPU bounding.
You can easily see
after Vulkan port,
the CPU load decreased
and then GPU load
increased because
the FPS increasing.
But with the GPU bounding
situation, just the CPU drop.
But because GPU is
already in the 100% busy,
so there's no way of
increasing more FPS.
So the good design policy
about the power budget
is making a reference load
with your former device target
and adjusting that load with
the other quality leveling
and also the different
performance target
adjustment for the lower
load for the all devices set,
and the higher load for
the latest device set.
And also you can consider
carefully, this budget is also,
you have to consider,
throttling situation.
And about performance
target, you sometimes
have to design your
performance target
with the resolution and FPS.
So HD 30 frame per
second is there,
then you can easily
imagine that increasing
your resolution to the full
HD will go up the GPU a lot.
But with both FPS and
resolution double,
then you can expect
easily to imagine
that the right side of
the picture, the GPU
will be the quadrupole
and CPU will be double.
It is quite higher increasing
load for both GPU and CPU.
And quality leveling is a
little bit more complicated.
You can tune your quality lever
for the effect or geometry
and character details, and
also resolution or texture.
But it also can
make a side effect
to give hardware memory
bandwidth and so on.
So you have to really
carefully design that and need
more better understanding about
the GPU and system inside.
So with this guidance
I have shared
during this session, the
policy design performance
target and also
the power budget,
we use this policy
for our partners.
And 90% of partnered
games get benefit.
It comes from the 15% to
get around the twice better.
And one main problem about this
guidance, because you usually
do not have any way to
measuring the load itself easily
with the other tools and
also just in the device.
So we are developing
our internal tool
that's shipping with the
Galaxy, called GPUWatch, that
will give you a better
understanding and a way
of measuring the load
within that budget
target of that device.
One more thing.
Is a plan to be integrated
into the developer option.
I cannot say--
I cannot promise when
that will be shipping,
but that will be shipping
at some day soon.
And for better understanding
about the tool,
we are working with the Google
and other GPU vendors like
GAPID and PerfDoc, RenderDoc,
and the vendor tools like
[? Snapter ?] and Profiler,
[? Molygraphic ?] [INAUDIBLE]
and the [? S5 ?]
[? streamline. ?] We are really
hard at work to support them and
improve that and shipping with
the more better
support the tool.
Summary is we try to
steer Vulkan-centric work
in the industry of
gaming under mobile,
but it is really
not that simple.
And so we continue
the heavy effort
to bring the quality of the
driver and better tooling.
Also will deliver better
and clear guidance
of the power budget
and perform target.
Really hope to
have your feedback.
Please contact again
gamedev@samsung.com
for any questions or feedback.
And I want to introduce
Ito-san and Enji-san to talk
about the Final Fantasy
XV Pocket Edition
as the best practices of
mobile game optimization.
KOSEI ITO: OK, hello.
My name is Kosei Ito,
and I am a producer
at Luminous Productions, one
of the Square Enix studio.
First, please take a
look at this short video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[DRAMATIC MUSIC]
[END PLAYBACK]
KOSEI ITO: OK, so
what you just saw
was our latest Final
Fantasy XV efforts.
We call it Final
Fantasy XV universe.
It is a universe that
has a console game, FFXV,
at its base.
It continues to
transcend all platforms
and expand its reach
throughout the globe.
Two years ago, Final
Fantasy XV, which
was released for
home game console,
become a huge hit, selling over
6.5 million units worldwide.
Now the mobile version
of Final Fantasy XV
comes to smartphone and tablet
with the Final Fantasy XV
Pocket Edition
that we would like
to showcase for you all today.
So please watch
this short video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[HARMONICA MUSIC]
- I think we can forget
about hitching our way there.
I thought people were
friendly outside of the city.
- You can only go so far on
the kindness of strangers.
- Come on, the car isn't
going to move itself.
- I thought the car was
supposed to move us.
- Wouldn't that be nice.
- Can it.
Ready, steady?
- Hey there.
Y'all kept a girl waiting.
Cindy, Cid's grease
monkey grand daughter.
If you're up to the
challenge, how about it?
- See you, slowpoke.
- I'm going up ahead.
- Noct!
[END PLAYBACK]
KOSEI ITO: Sorry, we
have some audio problems.
Anyway, Final Fantasy
XV Pocket Edition
underwent a major
optimization process
in order to bring Final
Fantasy XV to mobile devices.
The game has also
been root optimized.
And awesome game graphics
is just the start of it.
We logically changed
the look of the game
to match our target users.
The game was introduced
in a series of episodes.
And by the way, Galaxy played
a huge role in its development.
The game fully supported
DeX and Vulkan.
So now let's get
the lead programmer,
Yoshimasa Enji at
Summer Time Studio,
to showcase the activities
that we engaged in with Samsung
for Vulkan support.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: I'm going to
help him for translation.
Hello, my name is Enji.
I'm the CTO of Summer Time
Studios, the developer of Final
Fantasy FV Pocket Edition.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Here I
would like to talk
about optimization using Vulkan
of the Final Fantasy XV Pocket
Edition.
YOSHIMASA ENJI: Final
Fantasy XV Pocket Edition
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: One
of the major points
of Final Fantasy
XV, graphics-wise,
is its art style.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: While
being faithful
to the world of Final
Fantasy, we aimed [INAUDIBLE]
[? side, ?] which is like a
more friendly style rather
than a photorealistic one.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: In order to
bring this other style
to appeal wider audience,
we needed to create a new--
not an anime style, but
to produce an ambiance
of the visuals using new style.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: To
achieve that goal,
we discussed with
Unity technology
and eventually we
decided to adopt
post-processing stack of Unity.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So
post-processing stack
is Unity's new feature
set that can manage
multiple posts affecting to one,
and quite optimal to produce
great graphics effect.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: By adapting
the post-processing stack,
we were able to achieve
better graphics quality
and we were able to tune each
of the scenes in the game.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Not only do we
look in to the cutscenes,
but also during the gameplay,
we have tuned the performance
using the post-processing stack.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Quality
screenshot which
shows the difference
of quality is here.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So the
screenshots is comparable
before and after using the
post-processing stacks.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: For
each of the scenes,
we are able to choose
a graphics parameter
and we are able to achieve those
qualities that our artists were
aiming to.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: We used a
color grading [? broom ?]
and full-screen anti-aliasing.
And for some scenes
we adapted the depth
of field, motion blur,
and vignette and so on.
We used multiple post effects.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: But
as you can imagine,
those kinds of post-processing
would take a lot of GPU load,
and sometimes it went
to below 20 frames
per second on some
Android devices.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Our goal was to
achieve 30 frames per second,
so we needed to do some
kind of optimization
to achieve the goal of
the graphics quality.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So we worked
together with Samsung graphics
optimization team
and Square Enix
as well to achieve the goal.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Of our my initial
expectations, just having
the short time camp.
But eventually it became a total
of 53 days of support camp.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: While at the camp,
we optimized Unity engine side
and we are able to achieve
the goal using Vulkan.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: At first, we
built Unity using Vulkan.
We debuted its Unity Engine
using Vulkan settings.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: That's
a profiling result.
We found that the
multiple RenderPass
was being used, which can be
combined into one RenderPass.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So we added a quick
call to check RenderPass status
and merge multiple
RenderPass in to one pass.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: In the Final
Fantasy XV Pocket Edition,
we are using Unity
with this optimization.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: This
version of Unity Editor
is having as optimization
or bug fixes, like not
to crash the editor,
or some optimization
to [? makes ?] DeX support.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: The editor
crash that I mentioned,
that was originated from
our [? code side, ?] but it
was hard in our side to
work around those issues.
So we chose to have the Vulkan
on the Unity Editor side.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: By performing
the optimizations,
we're able to achieve the
CPU load from 60 millisecond
to 90 millisecond using Vulkan.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: In comparison
to OpenGL version,
OpenGL version was 18 frames
per second and Vulkan version
is 30 frames per second.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So that in our
case of Final Fantasy XV Pocket
Edition optimization, adopting
Vulkan API worked pretty well.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: We did some other
optimization, not limited
to Vulkan itself.
But we did some optimization of
our gaming code itself as well.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Samsung
Game Dev team also
contributed to
this part as well.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: For the post
effect, post-processing
as well, we did the optimization
of the code itself using Unity.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: That version of
optimized post-processing, this
is why it's different from
Unity's post-processing stack.
And it is selectable in
an option in the game.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: We are also keeping
the post-processing stack
option as is because
it can produce
better graphics quality.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: And we also
added lighter rendering option
to achieve a better performance
in a wider variety of devices.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: We did optimization
in the shader code as well.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Also, we added
a cap for the maximum number
of particles used in the game.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: And are not
limited to optimization.
Samsung Dev Team contributed
to fix some issues in the game
code and a lot of time
optimizations as well,
so we are very thankful to them.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: They did
tons of contributions,
but we cannot list
all of them here.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: And so a result
of optimization, in average
we were able to achieve
an increase of 10
frames per second in average,
and that maximum frame rate
was doubled.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So that
we have successfully
adapted post-processing
stack as an advanced feature
to achieve better quality.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: I am very proud of
[? our ?] [? art, ?] which was
able to achieve with co-working
with the Samsung and Square
Enix development team.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: We are able
to achieve better quality
and performance at the
same time using Vulkan
as our optimization techniques.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: This has been
a great opportunity for us
to achieve better quality
and to develop greater games.
Many thanks to the
people to contribute.
YOSHIMASA ENJI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]